example a knight and Bishop against the
opponent's bishop or Knight and Bishop
against the opponent's Knight is still
technically a draw so right now if Arjun
wants to play it safe he can just remove
this white Pawn from the board
remove the other white pawn and
yeah but then yeah those winning chances
just uh disappear so I think the only
way to keep the game alive is to
actually Retreat the bishop so that you
keep the past G Pawn under lock and key
yeah black can stop that pawn with his
push-up but okay we're gonna see the end
of today's match over the next few moves
why it's not stepping back
even if black spawns disappear remember
it is a draw but uh
okay he'll just try and keep those if
possible and Magnus doesn't even want to
hang around we're going to see this game
end with King versus King and Magnus
takes the first day of the final he does
I draw in the final game he could have
won it even Magnus but three games it is
over he takes the first match in
dominant fashion